good morning believe nation today's
message is improve yourself you just
blown me over to you Cristiano Ronaldo
you have to work I try to do it almost
every day this is why I'm in the top
level many many years
I think it's not it's not by confidence
it's because I do it extra outside the
pitch when I'm 12 years old most of the
people told me Christian we are very
very good talent player but you are very
skinny very slim and I'd put it in my
mind the body we can improve you can
improve you got gym dedication and not
work you can improve so I have improve
myself improve yourself anything
what do you do to improve yourself you
ask me really deep passions so I don't
really answer those I'll and better
really think of
do more in fact this for
what do you practice I get back depends
on what I want to improve what do you
want to improve right
you'll want to say you don't want to see
what you want to get been around huh
what are you improving alright cool I'm
excited to find out what happens one of
the things I'm trying to improve on is
being a better speaker and a better
storyteller and practicing and I'm
looking for a new mentor to help kind of
guide me through that process but I
think it's you know when you are not
learning when you don't feel like you're
growing then then life kind of sucks
right like we thrive when we're learning
new things and we're growing whether
that's in our personal lives in our work
if you are going to a job or in the
business and you feel like you're just
doing the same thing over and over and
over and over and over again then you're
not gonna be happy you're not gonna be
happy with your business and when you
come home you're not gonna be a good
husband or wife or father or mother and
so it's important that you are always
learning to improve yourself because if
you're not learning you're dying so
question that today is what are you
learning right now leave in the comments
below I'm curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another